that's cool man you gotta teach your
[__] kid and society ain't helping us
now with our kids to protect themselves
look at this [__] peanut thing look
at this [__] peanut thing
are you [__] serious you [__]
gentiles you're really gonna
you want your kids kryptonite to be a
[__] peanut
and you're looking at me like joey who
gives you the right thing i'm telling
you right now
i see i never even heard of this [__]
until my little baby went
trick-or-treating or some parent in
burbank
my little timmy don't eat peanuts
you know that's a [__] great why not
he's like he's allergic if he eats a
peanut he'll die
who told you this
she's like the doctor did i go you know
what do me a favor give him a peanut
just give him a peanut i guarantee he
ain't gonna [__] die okay
he'll drop on the floor and go on the
convulsions and [__]
but he ain't gonna [__] die big
[__] difference and you don't give
them a whole peanut
okay it's like having an eight ball you
don't do the whole [__] thing right
you do a couple bumps you get all jazzed
up you look out the window and then
you're right there
same thing you get a little peanut every
day you build up his [__] resistance
a couple years ago i had a cat that he
just liked to do coke there's nice to do
coke about 10 years ago
and i come home with an eight ball and
he'd do a couple bumps to cat but when i
not in his nose i'd spray it in his
mouth like put like a little
like a little coke on his fang towards
the end i was doing a chinese stuff
in a straw
his name was finney he loved it i love
my cats but that's not the [__] story
here
the story is at first he would do one
freeze towards the end he was doing half
an eight ball with me
i built up his resistance the same thing
with the [__] kid in the peanut
you got to build up his [__]
resistance give him a peanut every
goddamn day
until he's peter [__] free and he
doesn't have to live like that
think about it think about it and i know
some of you have nephews or maybe you're
children you're looking at me like joy
what the [__] do you know what the [__]
do i know
your son's not gonna be able to go to a
baseball game can't go to the [__]
circus
he can't fly southwest i mean you
when he gets old and he sees a hot chick
and he wants to get his dicks up if
she's eating peanuts
he can't do it he's he's got to walk
around with a chain with a peanut butter
and [__]
they put him in a classroom with eight
other kids freezing
waiting for a vaccine for the peanut you
can't do that to your child
there's enough jackets to put on kids as
it is today they can't [__] handle it
i'm a psychiatrist but i'll tell you
what
i'll tell you what whatever the [__] the
word is i don't know i
listen after four o'clock i don't [__]
with big words i'm a little stoned i
might say whatever
don't even throw a big word at me i just
stare at you right but
how i know this is because when i was a
kid and i came from cuba and i was very
insecure in the language and all that
[__] i was allergic to maple syrup
you know what being allergic to maple
syrup is like racism that's how bad you
[__] feel
okay that's how bad you feel because
when you're home you don't feel bad
because they won't make pancakes
until you go to summer camp in the bronx
with 18 other [__] gorillas
and they're eating eggs and sausages and
bacon and
french toast and pancakes and the maple
syrup is dripping down their [__]
faces
and here you are sitting there eating a
[__] yogurt in a banana like harvey
homo
eventually you [__] snapped me like
[__] this [__]
i'm eating the [__] maple syrup
and i ate the maple syrup i got a little
[__] up i went into a coma for a few
days right
that's why my eye goes that way but let
me tell you something
when i came out after a few days i did
the [__] thing again and i ate the
french toast again
and i ate it again i kept going back to
the hospital and my mother thought i was
[__] [__]
but today today i go to denny's once a
[__] month and have a [__] pancake
all right
so tell me my [__] i don't need to be
a doctor
i don't need to be a [__] doctor you
figure this [__] out in life
you know what else i was allergic to
that i would never be able to live my
life
dogs in the [__] worst way guys
you know when you're a little boy all
you want to do is [__] be around dogs
i was allergic to dogs so my throat
would lock up
i have to go to the hospital intravenous
spend the night crying
tears needles anxiety [__] it
and then what happened i kept locking it
up and after a few months every time i
see a dog i'd tighten up
now i took it into a different realm now
i started getting bit so i got bit in
the leg i got bit in the ass
like i bit in the face i said [__] it
every time i saw a dog i hugged that
[__] like i meant it
i just hugged them i didn't give a [__]
in my eyes hug them
little dogs dashoons chihuahuas
whatever you had i [__] hugged it all
right and today i got six cats
okay because i built the [__]
resistance ladies and gentlemen so
i know i'm a little off and you're
looking at me like joey what the [__] do
you know i know about life and giving
somebody a jacket
and it's bad enough you know why would
if your kid don't eat peanuts they got
the right to bully him
think about that those are the ones i
believe where the [__] is the lunchbox
[__]
and the sad thing is [__] let me say
some
this country was built on peanuts
this country was built on peanuts all
these you know what i'm talking about
this country was built on peanuts
you've been [__] broke you're moving
to a place you gotta give them first
last security little [__]
a refrigerator or a stove you're sitting
there you got twenty dollars in the bag
like a half a joint a valium
you're depressed about yourself how can
i be in this position in the middle of
all this sadness you're like holy [__]
i got two pieces of white bread i got
some jiff creamy
[Music]
and some welch is great i got a half a
container of bad milk but i'll shake
that [__] up real good
and i'll bring that peanut butter and
jelly to life and no matter how bad you
feel eat that peanut butter jelly
sandwich how [__] good do you feel
after you eat peanut butter and jelly
sandwich you're depriving me
that i [__] that i see a kid i don't
even care if he's my kid i [__] put a
snickers bar on that [__] [__]
it you'll thank me in 20 years
[__] trust me